la energía de ionización se refiere a la
energía que se requiere para remover un
electrón de un átomo neutro
así que si vemos aquí abajo está
representa un átomo neutro es decir
igual número de protones y electrones y
debido a que el núcleo con carga
positiva va a traer a los electrones con
carga negativa se requiere energía para
sustraer un electrón de la fuerza de
atracción del núcleo entonces esto es tu
energía de ionización si sus traes un
electrón ya no tendrás igual número de
protones y electrones tienes un protón
más que electrones y por eso aquí
tendrás una carga positiva de 1
por lo tanto formarás un guión así que
la energía de ionización siempre será
positiva siempre se requerirá energía
para sustraer un electrón así que
tenemos un valor positivo para la
energía de ionización
y nuestras unidades son kilo jules por
mol y en este vídeo sólo vamos a hablar
acerca de la primera energía de
ionización
y uno así vamos a ver algunas de las
energías de ionización reales para los
elementos en el grupo 1 y podemos ver
aquí algunos elementos en el grupo 1 y
para el hidrógeno se requieren mil 312
kilos jules por mol de energía para
sustraer un electrón del hidrógeno para
el litio se requerirán cerca de 520
kilos jules por mol para sustraer un
electrón y podemos ver que conforme
descendemos el número disminuye entonces
para el sodio sería 496 potasio sería
419 así que hay un patrón claro conforme
descendemos en un grupo en la tabla
periódica definitivamente disminuye la
energía de ionización
entonces tiene que ser más fácil
sustraer un electrón vamos a ver si
podemos encontrar la razón y vamos a
estudiar a detalle estos dos elementos
que son hidrógeno y litio
entonces comencemos y veamos estos
diagramas aquí vamos a llenarlos para el
hidrógeno y litio y así que para nuestro
primer diagrama pondremos el hidrógeno
el hidrógeno tiene el número atómico de
1 así que hay un protón en el núcleo
entonces hay una carga de más 1 en el
núcleo y en un átomo neutro hay un
electrón vamos a continuar dibujando en
el hidrógeno un electrón justo aquí así
la configuración electrónica sería 1s
así que un electrón está en el orbital s
en el primer nivel de energía y este
electrón con carga negativa es atraído
por este núcleo con carga positiva
entonces para sustraerlo debes añadir
energía si tú añades mil 312 kilos jules
por mol de energía puede sustraer es
electrón y si haces eso te quedarás sólo
con una carga positiva en el núcleo y
ningún electrón a su alrededor y si ya
no tienes un átomo neutro entonces
tienes un yo tienes h más porque hay una
carga positiva de uno en el núcleo y
cero electrones así que h más aquí está
el concepto de la energía de ionización
vamos a ver el litio aquí abajo
dibujaremos al litio
el litio tiene un número atómico de 3
así que hay 3 protones en el núcleo y en
un átomo neutro 3 electrones entonces la
configuración electrónica es 1 s 2 2s 1
así que hay 2 electrones en el primer
nivel de energía y están en el orbital s
voy a continuar dibujando los aquí estos
2 electrones que acabo de dibujar
representan los 2 electrones en el
primer nivel de energía en el segundo
nivel
hay un electrón más voy a poner ese
electrón aquí abajo así
entonces para el litio si sus traemos un
electrón el que es más probable en salir
sería este electrón externo el que está
en el orbital 2s así que si aplicas 520
kilos por mol de energía puede sustraer
ese electrón y si haces eso te quedarían
cargas positivas en el núcleo
y aún tendrías electrones en el orbital
es así que continuaré y los dibujaré
aquí pero has tomado el electrón externo
y por lo tanto aquí tienes un cat ión de
litio tienes el i + 1
porque ahora tienes tres cargas
positivas en el núcleo y sólo dos
electrones así que tres menos dos damas
uno la configuración electrónica para el
cast ión de litio sería por lo tanto 1s
todos porque hemos sustraído es electrón
exterior en el orbital 2s entonces esto
es la idea para la ionización del
hidrógeno y litio y vamos a examinar
algunos de los factores que afectan la
energía de ionización y así primero
hablaremos de la carga nuclear así que
continuaré escribiendo carga
y clear
aquí la idea de carga nuclear es que
entre más cargas positivas tengas en tu
núcleo el electrón sentirá mayor fuerza
de atracción y por lo tanto será más
difícil sustraer ese electrón
así que en general puedes pensar que un
aumento de carga nuclear haría
incrementar la energía de ionización
porque de nuevo hay una mayor fuerza de
atracción para los electrones así que
examinemos estas dos situaciones y vamos
a pensar primero en el hidrógeno el
hidrógeno tiene una carga más 1 en el
núcleo
y este único electrón aquí sería jalado
hacia el núcleo por esa carga positiva
si vemos el litio +3 en el núcleo así
que es una carga nuclear mayor sólo
pensando en la carga nuclear podrías
decir oh bueno este electrón podría ser
jalado mucho más que en el hidrógeno
porque más 3 es mayor que más 1 entonces
solo pensando acerca de la carga nuclear
para estos dos casos eso pareciera
indicar que el electrón exterior del
litio tendría una mayor fuerza de
atracción hacia el núcleo
por lo tanto podrías pensar que requiere
más energía sustraer ese electrón así
que solo pensando en la carga nuclear
podemos pensar en el aumento en la
energía de ionización
lo siguiente vamos a hablar acerca del
efecto pantalla de los electrones
excepto
ya
d
electrones o también podría llamarlo
ya
tú
electrónico
la idea del efecto pantalla de los
electrones es que los electrones de la
capa interna van a blindar a los
electrones externos de la carga positiva
del núcleo y ahora veremos al litio como
ejemplo de esto tenemos estos dos
electrones de la capa interna que van a
repeler a los electrones de la capa
externa así que este electrón el azul va
a repeler este electrón en verde y este
electrón en azul va a repeler este
electrón en verde y así van a blindar
este electrón externo en verde de la
carga 3 positiva porque los electrones
repelen otros electrones cargas
semejantes repelen a otras cargas
semejantes esta es la idea de efecto
pantalla de los electrones o
apantallamiento electrónico así que
pensando solo en este factor para el
litio estos 2 electrones del orbital
interno van a blindar a los electrones
del orbital externo
habrá una fuerza en la dirección opuesta
por así decirlo y esto significa que
será más fácil sustraer el electrón
externo debido a la fuerza de repulsión
de estos electrones y si solo pensamos
acerca del efecto pantalla de los
electrones o el apantallamiento
electrónico sería más fácil sustraer el
electrón externo del litio debido al
efecto pantalla y por lo tanto
necesitarías menos energía entonces
tenemos una disminución en la energía de
ionización si solo estamos pensando en
este factor ahora la carga nuclear y el
efecto pantalla de los electrones van de
la mano y una manera de relacionarlos
sería pensar acerca de lo que se conoce
como carga nuclear efectiva así que
continuaré escribiendo carga nuclear
efectiva como zeta
es igual a la carga nuclear que es z
menos el efecto pantalla de los
electrones así que esto es una manera de
pensar acerca de esto esta es una forma
muy simplista de hacer los cálculos así
que veamos primero el hidrógeno y
calculemos la carga nuclear efectiva que
este electrón experimenta bueno hay una
carga de +1 en el núcleo
esa es la carga nuclear zeta
y no hay electrones de apantallamiento
entonces 1 - 0 es por supuesto más 1 así
que este electrón externo experimenta
una carga nuclear efectiva de más 1
para el litio hay 3 protones en el
núcleo así que z sería más 3
y hay dos electrones de apantallamiento
estos dos electrones de la capa interna
de aquí así que sería más 3 menos
entonces la carga nuclear efectiva sería
de más 1 si piensas acerca de esto la
carga nuclear efectiva que el electrón
de hidrógeno siente es casi la misma que
la del electrón externo del litio porque
ambas tienen una carga nuclear efectiva
de más 1 así que el hecho de que el
litio tiene este efecto de pantalla de
los electrones o apantallamiento de
electrones esto cancela este efecto de
la carga nuclear y así estas dos cosas
se cancelan ahora desde luego esto es
una manera muy muy simplista de calcular
el efecto de la carga nuclear en
realidad para el litio si lo hacemos de
la manera más complicada se obtiene un
valor de 1 punto
3 aproximadamente entonces podemos decir
que la carga nuclear efectiva está cerca
de más 1 positivo a pesar de que es un
poco más preciso decir que es alrededor
de 1.3 y para nuestros propósitos el
efecto pantalla de los electrones para
el litio cancela ese incremento de la
carga nuclear y por eso tenemos que
echar un vistazo al último factor para
entender este patrón y el último factor
es la bilis
sea
de ese electrón externo hasta el núcleo
así que reflexionemos en esto para el
hidrógeno este electrón está muy cercano
al núcleo y entre más cerca esté tendrá
una mayor fuerza de atracción hacia el
núcleo entonces una vez más en la física
la ley de coulón es dependiente de la
distancia entre más cerca estás sentirás
más la fuerza de atracción así que este
electrón siente una fuerza de atracción
muy poderosa entonces es difícil
sustraer ese electrón para el litio este
electrón en la capa externa está en
promedio a mayor distancia del núcleo y
por lo tanto no tiene tanta atracción
hacia el núcleo no hay una fuerza de
atracción tan grande así que es más
fácil sustraer es electrón externo si es
más fácil sustraer ese electrón externo
desde luego significaría una disminución
en la energía de ionización
entonces debido a la distancia podemos
decir que es más fácil sustraer ese
electrón externo para el litio porque
está más alejado del núcleo y así
pensando en los tres factores al mismo
tiempo la carga nuclear y efecto
pantalla de los electrones se cancelan
mutuamente
y entonces podemos pensar solo acerca
del factor de la distancia para explicar
el patrón que vemos en los grupos para
la energía de ionización